this is a computer game called elite
this is really well elite I'll show you
in a minute where we load it up but this
is elite was the first really proper
game to use three-dimensional graphics
this current generation of gamers won't
remember a time when games weren't 3d so
before that time we had sort of games
like like this which is sort of this is
the version of pac-man for the BBC and
this is this comes on tape of course for
the this computer when the game came out
which was in 3d actually just blew
everybody away I mean the guys who wrote
this in my view geniuses I mean they
they wrote it
Belem Braben they wrote this while they
were undergraduates at Cambridge and
they were probably no more than 20 years
old when they wrote this and they made
the computer they made this computer do
something which nobody thought it would
could possibly do the program they wrote
was just a work of genius how they
managed to get this phenomenal level of
graphics onto this computer so you can
see this is a load it up shortly but
it's all wireframe of course not colored
in it's not shaded and lighter and lit
properly but this was this was
revolutionary for the 1984 I think it
was at the time I really became slightly
obsessed by this game much of me and I
played it and played it and played it
with my mate Pete siddaway
who was my friend at school and we
played this thing from ages and ages and
ages it's actually one of the first not
only one of the first 3d games invented
it's one of the most open-ended games so
there's no point to the game you can
either you can decide whether you want
to so there's no levels there's no lives
involved so computer games like this one
just previously you had you had three
lives if the monsters got you you died
and you moved on to the next life and
the game the idea was to keep going
through the levels and amassing as many
points as you could this game is
completely unlike that there's no levels
you just start off with a spaceship and
you can explore the galaxy wherever you
want to go so this computer this is it
when you bought it it came with it
didn't come with a disk drive or
anything what you did is you attached a
tape recorder to it
this is the tape for elite this isn't
the original tape recorder we had for it
that one broke after many years of use
so this is a tape recorder we had lying
around the house so the first thing I've
got to do is rewind the tape what I'll
do is I'll pull the plug out to start
with so you can hear the data because
this is the great thing about this is
you can actually hear the ones and zeros
that coming out of this this is the
leader so this is a very evocative noise
from my childhood so what you're hearing
there is ones and zeros which had been
recorded onto the tape and it literally
it stores one as one frequency of noise
and a zero as a different frequency and
it's just oscillating between those two
different frequencies noise frequencies
play so I'll stop that and I'll have to
rewind it again there and then we wait
oh no I don't rewind it far enough so
none of this instant put a disc in a
computer or boot it off a hard drive you
have to wait you had to be patient so
now it's confused because it's it's
loaded part of the data and I've told it
to rewind there we go so it's found it
notice all these ones and zeros all this
noise is being going into the computer
and being translated now into data the
first time I played this again was
probably first time in about 20 years
that I played it again and I got it down
from the loft
my parents loft and set it all up and I
actually let my kids play it and so I've
got a five-year-old daughter who really
really loved playing it she wasn't very
good at it
so now we have to wait about two two or
three minutes before it loads right so
the first thing you see this this is
just blew me away the first time I saw
her I thought this is absolutely
fantastic
you got a rotating wireframe graphics
spaceship on the screen and this was
just incredible we're moving from
pac-man to this was absolutely wonderful
right so we've got a cargo now we want
somewhere to go so we go to this local
chart here we'll use our arrow let's go
to Rio
Center the cross on there and we can
look up data on system so we can look at
what the planets like I still admit to
being slightly obsessed by this game but
no the other reason is that the way that
they put this data into the program so
this was you've only got thirty two K of
data to play with so they've created
with this 32k you've got a whole
galactic chart so these are full but
this is a galaxy of star systems each
with its own population each with its
populate different aliens populating a
planet and and different levels of
Technology and so on and there's eight
such galaxies there's absolutely no way
you can just store all this information
in 32k this is all generated randomly
generated with a so called random number
generator and that random number
generator they can use to spit out
whether the the planet is populated by
cats or by humans or whether it is
populated by whether the technology is
high-tech or the rings fill in the stone
age each one of these red buttons does
something each one of these function
keys does something I've lost the
original bar that came with the game so
I'm now going to press this button which
is going to launch into space so there
we are we're presented now with the
planet in front of us as a planet laughs
in front of us so this this diagram here
this tells us what's around us so as I
move through I move through space let's
increase our speed this is our speed
dialer gauge up down here rotates I'm
pulling up the spaceship now and
rotating back there's this there's our
space station what's that oh it's a
Python okay all right so it's firing at
us now because I've upset in life oh oh
that wiped out the front shields its
launch another missile I don't think
we're going to have we around very much
longer but so there goes our cargo
spinning off into space but after a
while I became more interested in
figuring out how it worked and I became
eventually became completely obsessed
with
how it worked
I programmed as well I call it game
there's not much to do with it with
solid graphics so this is wireframe
graphics but now I should have been
probably studying for my GCSEs stroke
a-levels I was spent more time writing
this than I was doing studying which
augments cause B to flunk my a-levels
actually the next generation computer
had more processing power and was able
to not only do wireframe graphics but it
could do graphics where you can shade in
the faces as well so I've actually
ported my game to the PC so I don't I've
taken the original code and put it on my
laptop actually now so I can show you if
you if you want to if you're interested
in seeing this so this is so this is
more modern yes so this is running about
a thousand times faster than that
computer but I learned to wait for it to
boot up now remember even though he's
coming out from sleep I can't have
switch it on I started programming it's
probably when I was about I was just
turned 17 I think it was and I still
tinker with it now when I originally
wrote this game it was the time when you
were a guy in the bedroom with a
computer you could like the guys who
wrote Elite you could make an awful lot
of money out of one person or two people
writing a computer game and selling it
so this is my dream right I was going to
sell I was going to write my my own
computer game and sell it on but I was I
was a bit too late really by the time I
sort of got anywhere in my game it was
be getting into the area where teams of
programmers were required to write games
now of course you know there's
practically movie studios or create your
own needed to write computer games
originally I wrote it in assembler which
is what the which is what elite is
written into in it that's the that's the
language that the processor understands
is that each so you write each
individual instruction that goes through
the processor so you a very very basic
command so you can write things like add
store subtract that's pretty much it
actually shifts are you multiply by two
and things like this so they're very
very
basic commands but once you can build up
code so you have to write an awful lot
of it but you can write routines and
things which will which will create
these fantastic graphics so originally I
wrote an assembler which was actually
for the acorn archimedes at the time I
wasn't writing for the BBC I was writing
an arm assembler which is arm is now the
processors you find in great majority of
mobile phones around the world
so acorn the original company that made
the BBC micro and the and the Archimedes
eventually went bust but not before it
spun off this other company called arm
which was the company that made the the
chip the processor for the acorn
archimedes and that chip is now used in
a tremendous number of mobile phones and
mobile applications all around the world
so I wrote an arm assembler but rapidly
became obvious that to get anywhere with
it was it's just too hard to write an
arm assembly you can't to make progress
faster I had to write in a higher-level
language so eventually I wrote it in C
and C has the advantage that you can
port it so it means you can take the
code you've written on one machine and
with only a little bit of tweaking if
you've written it just right you can
take that code and you can put it on
another computer and you can compile it
for a different computer so in fact I
took the code that I wrote for the
Archimedes and originally I ported it
over to the Mac and it worked just as
happy on the Mac with a bit of tweaking
and then when I got with my Mac iBook
and had a got a PC I ported over the PC
and I carried on just fiddling with it
reads I call this arena it's a sort of
it sounds a bit like something that it's
a nowadays it sounds a bit like a
something will be on a Gerry Anderson
film but sort of a combination of the
word aura and arena
so like arena is in battle and or is it
in something sort of slightly mystical
or something like with hindsight is a
slightly embarrassing knife but I can't
change it now it's the same I have to
stick with that name this is your
spaceship so unlike elite I've put a an
avatar spaceship in so there's there's
this there's the spaceship so this is
essentially what I had on the acorn
archimedes I put in more graphics over
time as the process of the computers
have gotten more modern
are able to handle it so the planet now
is got actually you know this is these
are the real continents on the planet
that's Africa there it mitad Li they're
a bit blocky so Africa coming up that
South America look there there's North
America there's Europe up there so I you
know it mucked around it and I've also
given earth some rings which she doesn't
have so this is something that elite
couldn't do is that I can fly backwards
in this so it's a paying newtonian
mechanics this means it's nothing to
look at compared with modern computer
games because yeah I've written
modern computer games are written with a
graphics engine in mind they're either
OpenGL or something like this or DirectX
or something like that whereas this one
I've written this is I've written the
graphics engine from scratch so this is
my own graphics engine in facts not
making use of any hardware acceleration
at all it's just running on the
processor this is I'm quite proud of
having to have written my own graphics
engine so I'm a physicist now I'm
employed by the University as a
physicist I think basically the writing
this this game is not a game by writing
this this bit of graphics here is
probably one of the biggest reasons why
I'm doing what I'm doing now and I
wasn't interested actually in going into
the computer games industry eventually I
decided that I was more interested in
writing the thing than playing it after
you're going to the computer games
industry you've got to be really
enthusiastic about computer games and I
just I couldn't you know couldn't care
less really but what it did do was it
taught me a certain way of thinking I
think a certain logical way of thinking
so in structured way of thinking
especially the debugging so-called
debugging of the programs is probably
teaches you a lot about logic and
finding your own answers to the problems
if you've got a program like this and it
doesn't work you've got a got to go
through the program and find out which
bit of the program doesn't work where he
made a mistake somewhere so you've got a
very logically go through step by step
and find out whereabouts in the program
the program is not working or not
working and quite the way you want and
sometimes all you get when you run a
program like like this after you've made
a change is it just spits out nothing it
just says segmentation fault or worse it
just crashes the machine entirely and
from that from that point you've got to
work out what what the problem is with
the program and it teaches you a very
logical structured way of thinking of
course physics is also a very you have
to think in a very logical way in terms
of coming about an experiment in physics
to try and work out what it is working
with the experimental or where the
errors are with the experiment this kind
of thing so so this is this probably
goes a long way to explaining what I am
now I have to admit it's slightly
addictive doing this but it is very
difficult I think nowadays and if you
pick up a machine like this this is a
complicated piece of equipment this PC
and to pick it up as a child now and
start to do a computer program is very
very difficult I mean you're not
presented with a cursor I guess in the
BBC micro when you can just start typing
you're presented with this you know
Mouse and graphics and all these windows
and things and if there's a lot of
distractions there you can't just
immediately start typing and your first
computer program and so on there's that
you know you've distracted by the
internet and all this other stuff
so you've really got a if you want to
start learning to program one of these
things you've really got a try you've
really got to know you got to download a
program like a basic program or C or
some compiler like this and then really
make an effort to try and start learning
programming whereas when you switch on
one of these BBC micros is practically
natural I mean you just wait for the
first thing you've got to do is start
typing commands into it well I'm not a
gamer at all actually I'm not um I don't
play computer games at all the only
computer game I'll admit to playing is
SimCity and I only play that
occasionally but I really not interested
in playing computer games and a lot of
people are but I became after elite I
became more interested in actually
writing the thing rather than and how it
worked which is part of the reason why I
never made anything of this they never
actually could be bothered to turn it
into a prefer anything more that you
could play and shoot shoot things and go
and do all the wonderful things that you
can do in elite with what's the future
for all Reena
this is probably it I find
and less time to do anything with it
these days is sort of probably in the
last week I've done more on it than I've
done in the past ten years
that's not supposed to happen so if
you've been doing some programming or
coding of your own whether it was 20
years ago or 20 minutes ago we'd love to
see it send an email to myself or Shawn
will I have the email address on the
screen and we'll have a look we love
that kind of stuff and who knows maybe
we'll put something here on computer
file by the way I'm in Shawn's office
there's no way I'd have this PC rubbish
leave comments underneath